c'est une bonne émission laisse pas
redescendre qui est matthieu delormeau
et merci matthieu delormeau et bien
mathieu ce soir j'aimerais vous avez vu
on a tous fait des petits trucs comme ça
quelle est la pire crise que vous ayez
faite dans votre vie ça remonte à la fac
ah oui il se trouve qu'à cette époque là
pour des raisons que j'ignore j'étais
pas très très costaud
oui sauf qu'en fait j'avais il y avait
un garçon qui s'appelle éric martin saha
marqueur hydrique marque indique martin
était à la fac
ouais et il avait insisté à l'époque que
je drague un policier et il sortait avec
la plus belle
non et j'avais tenté de l'approcher
j'avais raté et lui il avait choqué en
cinq minutes non ouais voilà
et il m'avait un peu ridiculisé derrière
parce qu'il avait laissé entendre que je
l'avais louper donc ça c'est éric martin
très réglée par un frère arthur non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en plus quand elle a combiné tous un rer
c'était à la fac de so what il venait
que sa bagnole qui a ramené les filles
le soir non le connard d'ogm été dit je
voulais casser la gueule à mais à cette
époque mère je me battais pas comme
aujourd'hui donc j'ai de plus quand vous
battez que c'est comme moi c'est
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui faut pas me faire chier ah
oui c'est à dire j'espérais chaud dans
ses tarifs je vais vous expliquer
quelque chose si vous battez c'est qu'un
problème passe calmement dans le regard
on voit déjà que c'est pas la peine
d'aller
mettez-moi coup de pression moi ça m'est
arrivé aux affaires mais voilà dans mon
vingtième simulation mais bien que dans
la
[Musique]
on va dans la rue on a revu la rue oui
oui et on vous allez mettre un coup de
son prix d'accord vous allez mettre un
couperet sur ces mots assez vous
annoncer que j'ai coupé alors allons
aussi alors on est là et attention vous
avez mais tant que je suis en lui est
hostile
on marche dans la rue parti bah du coup
oh [ __ ] pape est sa [ __ ] et oui ah
c'est toi qui l'a rallumé t'es chiant de
bénard
allez on regarde celui-là mais regarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un peu y'a pas de regards sont faits
rien souvent le chouf précieux jure que
c'est vrai j'ai déjà vu des gens alors
que changer de trottoir
mais quand vous leur avez fait ça à
cause du regard des regards non mais
c'est peut-être l'odeur celui qui se bat
c'est parce qu'on dit tiens j'ai une
chance grâce à ses montées bat pas là
alors autrefois on est dedans on est
dans le micro tu me regardent comme ça
quoi tu me regardent comme ça es tu as
perdu ta langue
hélas la troisième tracé baisse les yeux
c'est à dire à ses yeux
quel jeu m que les policiers faites en
coller une quand tu parles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
serial ata mère mais elle est pas là
donc ça toi je parle ce qui t'arrive
d'espèces de troisième avertissement
mannix qui va se passer au quatrième
avertissement vraiment savoir quoi ta
mère la pâte à reconnaître ses glaces de
chaud vraiment plus et faire une bonne
émission laisse pas redescendre
[Applaudissements]
s'émousser du salon histoire eric martin
ouais donc il
[Musique]